nous avons notre page d'espoir dominique
sopo
avec ce soir le match que tout le monde
attend la finale de la coupe de france
entre lens et paris saint germain et
pour les deux pour les deux équipes
c'est l'heure de vérité
oui pour le racing club de lens surtout
parce que ce racing club de lens en deux
rencontres contre le paris saint germain
ce soir et la semaine prochaine sur le
terrain d'auxerre les lensois peuvent
tout perdre ou au contraire décroché le
gros lot c'est à dire réussir le doublé
un privilège que peu d'équipés ont connu
et ce serait là un véritable coup de
maître car les lonsois jusqu'ici n'ont
absolument rien gagné c'est donc tout le
contraire des parisiens qui eux
possèdent un palmarès déjà éloquent et
qui faute d'avoir atteint leurs
objectifs principaux cette saison
disputeront cette finale comme une sorte
de lot de consolation à l'ado regorgent
christophe monteil nous sépare lance du
paris saint germain qui s'affronteront
ce soir en finale de la coupe de france
les motivations d'abord le paris saint
germain a raté son principal objectif le
titre reporte ses espoirs dans la coupe
l'an siège de tout palmarès se lance à
la conquête du doublé coupe et
championnat
les moyens financiers ensuite le paris
saint germain le plus gros budget avec
320 millions de francs alors que le
racing club de lens dispose de trois
fois - ci au club de la capitale nerf de
la guerre c'est l'argent dans l'ancienne
cité minière c'est la ferveur populaire
qui subliment l'équipe le lien
régionaliste qui unit le racing club de
lens son public est unique en france
impact populaire il a toujours été
réussie allons-nous semaine dernière on
était dans l'est dans les bas-fonds dieu
de la première division des 27 mais nos
moyennes donc moi je mettais un chievo
rapport à la ferveur populaire regarder
en étant l'entraînement d'ailleurs
peut-être mélo 400 personnes qui sont
leurs entraînements le racing club de
lens meilleure attaque du championnat
résolument orienté son jeu vers
l'offensive un football sans calcul
dépourvu de tactique attentiste était
partisan du jour en cif quand je suis
revenu à lens j'ai
je faisais partie d'un milieu de terrain
où il y avait plus des créateurs donc on
a pris énormément plaisir et puis j'ai
toujours essayé de prendre ce plaisir
sur le jeu essayer d'inculquer un petit
peu c'est cette fois son jouer avec
trois attaquants
c'est bien pour les attaquants donc ça
leur permet de s'exprimer le paris saint
germain disputera sa septième finale en
sept ans la dernière pour son président
michel denisot dans le bilan cette
saison par rapport aux ambitions
affichées reste mitigé ce qui compte
c'est la soirée de samedi qui le sera je
crois une belle fête de foot pour le
pôle et pour le club puisque on sera
présent en lever de rideau en finale de
gambardella ce qui a un sens ce qui veut
dire que la formation au psg s'est
considérablement développé c'est pas
l'image de marque du club ya quelques
années et je crois que dans le placement
des de la formation en france qui sera
rendu public dans quelques temps on sera
deuxième premier ça je suis assise
beaucoup là dessus parce que c'est le
vrai le vrai héritage lens paris saint
germain une finale explosive entre deux
équipes voué corps et âme à l'offensive
quoi qu'il arrive un beau vainqueur sera
couronné ce soir dans le plus grand
stade de france